- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- Wow!
- [Kelly] It is so nice to meet you!
- This is so pretty!
Happy birthday, by the way!
- [Kelly] Thank you!
I want someone to buy me a fanny pack now.
Like, I didn't know it was that dangerous.
That's amazing, that fanny pack scene.
- [Ke] Yeah, we had an
amazing time making that.
It's really cool.
- How long did it take to do
just that one fanny pack scene?
Like, to learn all of that?
- Well, it took weeks.
I trained with the action team for weeks.
And, you know, because
when you're in a movie
with Michelle Yeoh, and
there's action sequence,
I mean, she is the queen of martial arts.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- So, yeah, you know,
I wanted to make sure
that I did a good job.
So, I trained for weeks
with our action team.
In fact, I even brought the
fanny pack home and trained.
And imagine the fanny pack
is six to seven feet long.
And I was constantly swinging
that thing in the house.
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Ke] So, I was swinging
it, practicing it
to make sure I perfect it.
And the thing is, my
wife wasn't too happy,
'cause I was constantly breaking things.
- Oh my gosh.
She made you pick that
up, I'm pretty sure.
- Yeah, but it was pretty cool.
I mean, I'm glad it turned out well.
I'm very proud of it.
- I just love that it was
done with a fanny pack.
There's nothing funnier and more awesome.
I just love that it's a fanny pack.
I also love The Goonies.
And I know that you're probably like,
"We're still talking about this?"
And, yes, we are.
(audience laughing)
Because it's one of my, like,
it's one of the films that
shaped me as a child, I love it.
And I've had, like, I feel like
three or four cast members now on my show,
which I'm very lucky.
- [Ke] Wow!
- Exactly!
Josh Brolin was just here.
Anyway, Steven Spielberg cast
you in that right away, right?
- Yeah! This was right
after Indiana Jones.
- Which I loved!
- Thank you, thank you.
And I remember, I heard the
pitch from Steven Spielberg
for the very first time.
I walked in his office,
and as always, he greats me
with a big smile and a big hug.
- [Kelly] Aw!
- And he says, "Ke, I got your next movie.
"It's called The Goonies
and it's about seven kids
"finding a treasure map
"and they go on this amazing adventure."
- [Kelly] What?! You didn't
even have to audition??
- [Ke] No, no!
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- [Ke] 'Cause I already
auditioned for Indiana Jones.
- Oh my gosh!
- And he told me that
I was gonna play Data,
who is a James Bond, 007 character,
who has all these cool gadgets.
- That jacket, ah.
- But they never work unless
my life depends on it.
And sure enough, a few months later,
I was on the set with six other kids,
standing in front of a
giant, breath taking,
full size pirate ship.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- And it was just incredible.
- It's like camp for
kids, it's, like, awesome.
(audience applauding)
(Ke agreeing)
Oh my, did you ever keep anything?
- Oh my god, you know, had I known,
I would've kept everything.
But, I did keep the Data jacket,
which is one of the coolest jackets.
- [Kelly] Which is the best part!
(Ke agreeing)
You open the jacket and then
it attaches to the trash can
and it's raining (gasps)
I love the whole thing.
Okay, so--
Oh, no, I've definitely
have seen it 1,000 times.
So, everyone also knows you as
Shorty from Indiana Jones, as well.
Which you've been in such epic
films, like right off the bat
at such a young age.
So, do you remember
working with Harrison Ford?
- Yeah, oh my god, it was incredible.
- [Kelly] You worked
with some awesome people
right off the bat!
- [Ke] Yeah, first time ever, right?
Yeah, he was incredible.
He was, like, one of the most generous,
down to earth human beings I've ever met.
And I remember we shot a
lot of the exterior stuff
in Sri Lanka.
And we all stayed in this hotel.
And every day after we wrapped,
we would go and hang out
at the swimming pool.
And when Harrison Ford found out
that I didn't know how to swim,
he says, "Ke, come on, lemme teach you."
So, to this day, I learned
how to swim is because of him!
- Harrison Ford taught you how to swim?!
(audience applauding)
What is your life?!
I think I had a swim instructor
at the Y or something.
Wait, what? That's crazy!
- Yeah, yeah.
- I love that, 'cause it's
not always that way for kids,
like, starting out.
Like, I love that, that was
such a positive experience
right off the bat.
That's so cool!
- I got really lucky.
I mean, who would've thought, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- I mean, get to work
with Steven Spielberg,
George Lucas, and Harrison Ford?
It's incredible, yeah.
- [Kelly] Right off the bat!
Okay, you're touched by God.
(audience laughing)
So, and you're also talented,
that's the main reason.
- Aw, thank you.
- But you also fell in
love with Tae Kwon Do
while doing the film, right?
- Yeah, on Indiana Jones.
You know, they had a trainer,
and I had so much fun beating
up bad guys in the movie,
that after the movie I
took training seriously.
I studied Tae Kwon Do for many years.
- Wow, that's so cool!
I love that.
Well, that's important
because, like we just saw,
you use martial arts in this film.
So, it's called Everything
Everywhere All At Once.
And so, tell me more about it.
Like, why are you such a
bad ass with a fanny pack?
- Well, first of all,
it's a big science fiction
action drama comedy.
- Love.
- And it's about a family
who are disconnected with each other.
And they have to journey
far, far into the multiverse
to find themselves again.
And it's a great movie about what if's and
what our lives could've been like
had we made different choices in our life.
- Love!
- And it's highly
original, very inventive.
Written and directed by The Daniels.
It's with Michelle Yeoh,
Jamie Lee Curtis, James Hong.
I mean, the movie is incredible!
And I can't--
- [Kelly] Touched by God!
- Yeah, I can't believe
I get to be part of this
after a 20 year hiatus from acting.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] I love that though!
You know why?
You're just waiting for
those really awesome roles.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] "Nah, I'm just gonna wait for
"these really awesome roles to land here."
Well, the new movie is amazing.
Everybody has to go see it.
There's more than just the
awesome fanny pack moment.
It's called Everything
Everywhere All At Once
and it's in theaters nationwide right now,
y'all gotta check it out.